- You have shower advice in your book.
This is interesting.
- Yep, (laughs) yep.
- What your shower advice-
- Shower advice?
- Yeah, go ahead.
- Well, I mean we talk
about brushing, you know,
brushing your teeth in the shower.
- Here's the thing, I don't regularly-
Let's re-cap.
- Yeah.
- 'cause we talk about this more.
I don't regularly brush
my teeth in the shower,
I just, I do if I'm in a hurry.
Now I do happen to be in a hurry
- A lot.
- Often.
(audience laughs)
- So, it happens often.
- So it happens, yeah.
- That's fine because that's
where you are in the world
with that.
- That's where I'm at.
That's my choice.
- I'm on the whole other side
where I find it to be gross.
(audience laughs)
And I don't do it, and I
think there's another mention
of like maybe washing
your legs in the shower,
like get all the way.
You know, don't just
leave your ankles out.
(audience laughs)
- But wait, when you're washing
up here, it does wash down.
- That's how you're-
See, just different-
(audience laughs)
Different approaches to life is fine.
- Well, I mean, I'm also-
- It does.
I guess I shave my legs almost
every day in the shower,
so I'm kind of
doing it anyway.
- You're good down there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But like-
- Do you pee in the shower?
These are real hard questions.
(audience laughs)
No?
- I would lie if I said
I had never done it.
(audience laughs)
But I try not to.
- I pee almost
every time in the shower.
- That's awesome.
(audience applauds)
I'm glad that you're
open enough to say that.
That's great.
- No, but here-
You can't help it.
It goes back to that
childhood sleepover, you know,
they put your hand in the
hot water, sometimes you pee,
'cause it's hot water.
- So every time-
- The hot water
hits your body.
Not every time.
- But it's a lot.
- But like,
if I gotta go.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean,
I'm not against it.
- And it's goin'
down the drain.
- I've not never done it.
When I do do it, I always feel so ashamed.
(audience laughs)
- You know what I feel?
I feel productive.
(audience laughs)
I feel like I've knocked
a lot out.
- Two things at once.
- I'm brushin' my teeth.
- Two.
- I'm doin' everything at once.
- Multi-tasking.
- You know what,
I'm always in a hurry.
- I feel you.
- I wanna stay
in bed as long as possible.
- I feel ya.
- And then
roll out, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
And just be ready.
- Yeah, and be ready.
- So are you like-
- It's official.
- 30 minutes?
- We can't be
- 45 minutes to get ready?
- Roommates.
Ooh, no, I get ready in
seven minutes. (laughs)
- Oh, you're a quick one.
- Yeah, that's why people,
I just was in Montana,
and this little girl,
her mom was liked, "This
is Kelly Clarkson."
She's like, "No it ain't." (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- It is.
- And I was like,
you're absolutely right.
Kelly Clarkson's on TV.
This is Kelly Brianne. (laughs)
- That's right.
- Yeah.
I look very different.
- For real.